[Music]
now we're going to kind of switch gears
a little bit as Jay was saying and
talked about this new concept of
gravitational waves and for that I'm
going to have to work a little bit of
with analogies and then try to kind of
bring a concept that is very familiar to
you but perhaps never told in this way
so we all know gravitational waves are
things we use commonly to just get to
know whatever universe as I'm speaking
my vocal cords are perturbing the air
that produce some waves actually no
going all the way to your ears and
that's how we get to communicate this
morning you've heard you've seen also
sort sort of examples of how we've been
picking at the universe with the
electromagnetic observations ever since
Galileo pointed his telescope to the sky
we started learning wonderful things
about our universe that both answer
questions but more often than not open
new vistas to the universe and presented
new challenges to researchers we are on
the verge on the beginning of exactly
the same kind of revolution on this era
sort of messengers from our universe so
just to keep an analogy in mind let's
think of this duck just paddling its way
on in this pond even if we're far from
the dark and we don't even see it we can
see the ripples coming to us if we're in
this kind of from one of the edges of
the pond and by understanding these
ripples on how close they are the crests
from each other we can tell where the
duck is paddling fast or is kind of calm
or whatever and this is very much that
this picture we have to keep in mind
when we think of gravitational waves and
as I saw this curve as we go along of
course we can have a something larger
than the duck this Swan is paddling its
way and then as you can see the seagull
is just go bobbing up and down as these
waves produced by the by the Swan are
going by it in its own the the seagull
is not producing strong surface waves on
this pond but we can tell definitely
that this one is much more important
much more revelant relevant in producing
these disturbances the
the Dundas Eagle and of course if
someone goes and skip a rock we can tell
by the shape of these waves that are
produced at the rock is skipping in
which direction the rock were thrown and
how successful the person trying to skip
was so I think introduced a very radical
idea in 1915 as changes mentioned which
he basically told us let's stop thinking
of gravity gravity as an interaction
that produces forces let's just throw
that away and think of the whole
universe as being a fabric this fabric
can be bent by matter or energy as Gil
said this morning and so in this picture
where we have earth here we see imagine
the fabric around Earth being the store
been bent by the presence of the earth
itself and the satellite that otherwise
we would have thought in Newtonian
theory is going around because the earth
is pulling from it with the
gravitational force now has this is the
only trajectory can go in this band
space-time Einstein's theory had many
many radical new predictions once you
buy that concept of gravity of the
universe as a fabric one of them we
heard many times today that a space that
has been curved will curve everything in
pretty good curved trajectories from
distant objects like a star which as it
travels in a non curves part of this
this fabric will go in a straight line
but as it comes here it feels this
curvature turns around and for an
observer on earth we're going to imagine
what we're in a picture that the
observation actually took place here and
this is this phenomena of gravitational
lensing and this is one example in
addition to the ones you saw this
morning where we have four images here
they're actually produced by a star that
is for a set of stars are behind this
Center Co accumulation of matter there
is bending the space I'm here and we see
four images of that same object but
there was more to it I mean once you buy
a little bit of a theory everything
comes with it in particular the fact
that if you now have masses that
themselves are bending the space-time
that happen to interact or the
distribution of this matter
is changing dynamically it produces
these ripples very much like the duck
paddling on the pond and these ripples
go away onto the edges of the universe
and if we have the right detector we can
use these messengers who try to infer
what was what was being producing these
these ripples very much like the duck is
it duck paddling faster or slower we're
gonna be asking questions what produced
the ripples we see as these ripples go
around the introduce distortions of the
space-time so the ripples will propagate
of the speed of light and things that
are traversed to it get elongated in one
direction shrunk in the opposite and
this just goes in a cycle so the poor
seagull that before was going up and
down now will get squeezed from head to
toe and then elongated in the opposite
under this thing will just continue as
the wave passes through of course once
we want to go after them because the
process some very interesting properties
one of course is a new window to the
universe we want to ask questions what
is out there in and how much can we
infer from these signals there are
objects as we discussed they can only
produce signals in this channel and not
in the standard channels electromagnetic
that we have been using to probe either
your our universe so we have to ask well
is it really worthwhile go in afternoon
do we have enough sources are the
strength or the signals we'll have
enough for us with our technology to go
after them and this is not not a trivial
question it took us a hundred years for
technology to catch up with our
imagination or to catch up with
Einstein's imagined imagination because
the strength of these wave forms have to
do with the compactness so how much
matter have we piled up in a small
enough region times that inverse
proportionality with a distance so the
further away they are the weaker the the
signal or the perturbation would be and
there is also some dependence how fast
the source is varying so this is one
problem we have to face but this problem
also has an advantage which is they
interact very weakly if we were to stir
up we only see a ceiling we don't get to
see the sky because the light that is
coming gets to interact very strongly
with the roof of this building and with
us
go through while gravitational races go
through unimpeded so this is Kahn
because they interact very weakly pick
and it takes a very difficult effort on
the technological side to go detect them
but on their hand because they get the
they are so weakly interacting they are
very pristine messengers of the source
that produce them so we need we need to
look for the strongest possible sources
and these are the ones who will have the
highest compactness because there is
nothing we can do with distance if they
are far they're far what can we do so
we're ready so in dario's talk that
different objects that have more and
more dense with bend the space-time
around them in in more extreme ways so
the Sun does a little bit an engine
starter it's almost a black hole but not
quite that's more than any black hole
eventually just stretches in such a
small at such a large way that the most
radical things in the theory arise and
once you put this number together you
can tell what is the relative changes in
this distance of the safe the size of
the signal that will be changed by these
waveforms and typically we expect
numbers of the of the order of 10 to the
minus 19 so this is the relative change
in any length that we should be prepared
to measure in order to detect these
waveforms well finally we were able to
do that I mean community community got
together and over four decades
continuously improving the technology
we've got to create IDC tectors they are
incredibly sensitive as you will hear
more in the next talk and even with that
sensitivity the signal is buried in the
noise so we have to go from the
theoretical point of view and try to
help as much as we can because what
we're looking for is a needle in a
haystack and as much information as you
can give to the detector of what is it
that you should be looking for the
better not only to produce a detector to
allow the detection but also to ask what
sort of needle you have we want to use
as I said not just a detection itself
but to understand from the detection
what was the source that produced them
and this is just a just an illustration
of some things we do theoretically to
try to infer in a collision of two
neutron stars say what are the way from
scare acoustics and for
we need to bring all possible tools into
the problem very intense theoretical
calculation exploiting the most massive
part of the computers out there and
pulling everything together to predict
what's going to happen so two of the
most important or most relevant systems
that we are after are systems that
contain black holes and we heard about
them before as a region the black holes
region where nothing can escape as
they're described their main suspect in
the most energetic phenomena that we see
in the universe every time something
goes bang in it with a very very loud
way if you go leap inside chances are a
black hole had something to do with it
so they are like the bad boys of the
universe decisis they can go from a very
few solar masses to 10 to the 10 solar
masses and they China as I said some of
the most intense electromagnetic energy
said we have seen so far the next king
is the neutron stars so we've already
heard of all them these are stars that
have the masses of the order of the Sun
but they are compacted in the region of
about 15 kilometers just to put some
interesting number two with it if I were
to throw this pointer to the ground here
it would just break in pieces the energy
again it will just be transferred in
that collision and we're gonna get
nothing out of it that we can use almost
like a weak laser pointer but if you
were to do exactly the same exercise on
the surface of a neutron star once this
thing hits the ground it's going to
release about the same amount of energy
that a nuclear bomb so what are the
opportunities and where you'll hear more
about as we go along because this is a
window with that we just open we want to
check where Einstein was right we have
been riding this beautiful theory for
about 100 years but maybe at some point
it will give signs of cracks and that
would be beautiful because that will
begin to point out what we replace it
with a novel is true we haven't tested
this far and we're going to hear some
about it today we want to know about the
origins of some of these mysterious
energetic events and in particular if we
were to collide these two neutron stars
which we know should be happening
eventually and Lyell should be able to
detect them we may even see the birth
cry of a black hole one of the possible
outcomes of the collision of two neutron
star
they are coming and smashing against
each other at about the fraction of the
speed of light is a black hole so not
only can we witness and undetected the
gravitational waves are in the process
but get to see the most detailed process
by which a black hole is born so
ultimately what we want is to be able to
add to this amazing observations on the
electromagnetic side that we have been
doing a lot of physics with what we call
the dark messengers of the universe
which we now is know as gravitational
waves it's a complementary window to the
universe and the combination of the two
will give us amazing things just to give
you an example we heard this morning
about transients so and Bicky said when
you look at transients you don't know
what to look you just point and hope
that something is going to happen
unlikely nature always keeps something
interesting but now with gravitational
waves as these two objects are coming
together as you see in the next talk
you're going to we're going to have
waveforms from very early epochs till
the merger takes place where we have the
main band it will be a very interesting
possibility of using gravitational waves
to warm to tell us when and what to look
because the fireworks about to start and
this is one of the most exciting
possibilities and some of the things
that we've been doing actively research
on and with that let me stop and thank
you
[Applause]